and when welcome to this video playing
tiger tank from Norway and it's a
surprisingly popular line don't quite
understand why I mean it looks like
black and sound getting a decent game
pretty easily so we'll see I expect
something okay expected something funky
to happen but you didn't do it and one
day of this election idea trying to take
there quickly Bishop f5 Reserve is an
ambitious looking move even just
capturing is quite good
I actually like it six it's just a very
decent fringe let's just do this
threatening to take on before now babies
with their very simple means like
context pawn takes Bishop before
okay I expect 93 and then capture with a
piece there or this move which is kind
of comparable even though it clocks up
the development a little bit more so
probably just this move a tick well but
if I have taken I take that can actually
take me five in this situation huh so
well Kay Bishop d7 cannot be terrible so
that's just you should be seven books
you ain't a very logical most wait a
looksie ain't make sense I mean he takes
you for now threatening to win material
so what now what does he just take with
a pawn yeah he does okay that's a good
good position for black but okay you're
not losing material so I'm Knight e5
Knight a5 looks cogent right C form and
Bishop a4 s also on the a bishop a force
actually move Knight c3
[Music]
okay let's do this first so that I'm
more flexible don't worry about the pawn
bishop a 493 it was just about holding
it so yeah well now I can do this I'm
sorry now I can do this
Knight b3 that special before that we'll
bring material
okay so Bishop c3 now wins wins material
and I take these five yeah I can just
take with a pawn probably okay so I mean
that that that that route cannot run
anyway so I can do this move also can
play this move
pneumatics good good control and no
particular problem so I can take it now
I can still see if I can find a better
better movement it will probably not
have we actually ticks with the night
move okay
right III doesn't net anything yes I'd
like I like this idea take and now just
double on the C file it's a fairly
simple approach C 3 I don't know nothing
wrong about it I and I know this one and
I'm winning the airport that's what I
was thinking at least okay no let's use
all the pieces I will get four so was a
good move here trading a look yeah but
I'm still having this on the agenda I'm
going to trade this rock that makes the
technical play quite a bit easier you
can't stop those
yes yeah it winter position to open in
general stick - yeah why not
to dominate the night Bishop c4 and then
the corn should fall actually quite
easily
yeah it was a pretty clean wind I think
mostly due to the very good opening
position with Linus extremely popular on
the non professional level for some
reason and I don't understand why really
because I mean like having good position
instantly really white structure is
weakened and this is just a pretty bad
version of I don't know what exactly an
advanced CARICOM or something like is
just just very okay here this is already
a bit problematic as you can also see by
the engine evaluation I could have
probably played more incisive even but
this is this is very very solid he can
never really take that's almost made the
transition introduces ending is just an
extremely good for me week we bear the
whole Queen side is weak and the bishop
on d7 that I did not put on some outs of
the phone chain always almost always has
something good to do one a4
yeah here I don't know this looks good
but he's got 93 and then I basically
have to go back this is why I played a
waiting move or a small strengthening
move and it just it's just not good
catching just invading with all the
pieces them okay yeah we neither the
exchange okay you can just pick up all
the weak palms yeah that line is a real
argument to play the other cards and
people play this 393 it's completely
harmless and just good for black thanks
for watching